Man, the ringing is really loud today huh?
Wait, what do you mean I’m the only one
that can hear it? Ohhh that’s awkward.
Hey Guys Julia here for DNews
The Hearing Health Foundation estimates that
right now as many as 50 million people in
the US hear something that isn’t there.
A ringing, a buzz, a hiss, a crackle or pop,
are all the sounds tinnitus can make. And
in 90% of people with tinnitus, it’s caused
by hearing loss, through aging, noise exposure
or an accident.
So how can sound damage your hearing? Well
Tara talk did a good explainer on that in
a previous video, check out a link to that
in the description below.
In a nutshell, sometimes the energy from the
loud sounds or from prolonged exposure can
damage the coating of the auditory nerve that
carries sound signals to the brain.
And once these cells are gone. They’re gone
for good.
But how does that cause a ringing in the ears?
Neuroscientists at Georgetown University Medical
Center say the annoying and sometimes debilitating
sounds are the brain trying to repair itself.
A loud noise or extended exposure to noise
raises the activity of certain neurons in
the brain. For most people, these neurons
calm themselves after a while, but for those
with tinnitus, these cells remain hyperactive.
It’s like your nervous system is trying
to overcompensate for the loss, but instead
makes everything noisy.
Tinnitus can be debilitating. An estimated
2 million people find their lives seriously
impacted by it. Not only can you not hear
things that well, like your buddy next to
you at the bar, but you have a constant ringing
in your ear. You might never hear the sweet
sound of silence again. This can make a lot
of people anxious and have trouble sleeping.
I don’t mean to sound like a stodgy old
person, but hearing loss is serious. The World
Health Organization estimates that over a
BILLION that’s right, that’s with a b,
are at risk for hearing loss. And it doesn’t
just affect old people. For the past two years,
I’ve had constant ringing in my left ear
and some nasty hearing loss, probably from
listening to music too loud. I’m like an
old lady always saying “what did you say?
Speak up Sonny!”. Trust me it’s not a
good time. And I’m not alone, The WHO estimates
that over 43 million young people between
the ages of 12–35 years live with disabling
hearing loss.
Some studies, like one published in JAMA showed
that hearing loss in young folks is on the
rise. Ten years ago 1 in 5 adolescents suffered
hearing loss in 2005-2006 and the rate is
increasing. The WHO says that half of all
teens and young adults are exposed to unsafe
sound levels from personal audio devices.
Worst of all there’s no real treatment,
once your hearing is gone, it’s gone. Humans
can’t regenerate hair cells in the inner
ear like some birds and reptiles can. So prevention
is key. Take ear plugs to concerts, turn down
those headphones, and take a break when you’re
in a noisy environment.
Alright guys, do you guys ever get that annoying
ringing in your ears after a concert or listening
to music?